All right you've completed
the course content.
Now it's time for Meme 2.0
putting on the finishing touches.
In this iteration we'll add navigation,
a Table View, a Collection View and
get even more practice with delegates.
Similar to the lesson that guided you
through the first version of Meme
the upcoming lesson a self guided.
And focuses on skills
specific to building Mime.
We're going to ask you to look
into a few new topics as well.
Like Tab Views, Collection Views and
how to use a shared data model.
These are not trivial topics as
always be sure to reach out for
help if you get stuck.
You're almost done with the course.
Now get psyched to bring your
portfolio project to the next level.